you know every time I have a hot
reaction I find myself wondering huh
what's going to be the beginning clip of
the YouTube video and I have a feeling
it's going to be this okay what's going
on everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined by
gasps not icon Adam Richman you know him
from as many TV shows including Travel
Channel's man vs. food as well as his
books America the edible and straight-up
tasty Adam welcome to the show thank you
very much how are you with hot food I
always ask that but with you your
reputation precedes you a little bit yes
yes I think that doing that versus food
people operate into the assumption that
I ate like that in my day to day life
that five-pound burritos and like death
wings were part of the staple I assure
you they are not in any way and it's
been a hot minute since no pun intended
since I've run again like this yeah my
Georgia photography Tom Dodson shadow 50
Dodds has a term called Hickory whole
and I feel this is definitely this is
the highway to Hickory hold right here
[Music]
[Music]
I don't think it's funny that Khalid
King here with his own chef
I had three flames and he was out it's a
[ __ ] these wings is money
the major key son a dud son here you
hinges [ __ ] boy that was wonderful
alright so the fans would kill me if I
didn't get a rundown on man vs. food I'm
a bunch of questions for you right of
all the food challenges you did which
one was the most painful the one spicy
one that I lost is in Sarasota a place
with the ever so subtle title of
munchies 4/20 cafe open from 420 to 420
refire in your whole wing challenge use
ghost chili extract anyone can put
extract and something and make it hot
but when you balance heat and flavor
that I think takes degree of culinary
skill and also that's the challenge it's
like god it's good but it [ __ ] hurts
you know what I need it's of the chef
and we have it we have it JP we have it
on the microphone we do because Mike was
open they added it was jet black ghost
chili extract and his akina's boys go to
hit the whole bottle it just pullin out
and my director Dan cornfield it was his
first episode it's the first episode of
season 2 that we shot it was this first
episode out of the gate he didn't know
that he had the wherewithal to like stop
tape go back oh no you can't do that
and the reason why I'm especially mad is
not because of my record I'm gonna [ __ ]
about that it's that it's Cavalier and
very dangerous yeah I was going to say
you can't really mess around with stuff
like that when they weaponize ghost
chili extract and police grenades in
India they tie the actual Naga hello Kia
defences to keep wild elephants at bay I
was so jacked up in the bathroom of the
place that my tongue had swollen my
aides will passages have swollen
this is not to be trifled if I I dare
not speculate what's going to happen to
me and to the world a lot of these
places like if you finish the challenge
maybe they'll give you 10 bucks our free
meal or take a picture of you and put
your picture on the wall right what's
the weirdest prize that one of these
challenges had the end now that you
think back it's a great question you
stand out bubs big ugly in Carmel I
believe in
Indiana depending upon how many of the
big ugly burgers you finished you get a
progressively larger picture on the wall
up to a life-sized picture on the wall
if you finish a certain number of them
presumably because it's a memorial
you've already died like that's the last
vestige of you that your family will
ever have of all you at 37 victories
which one are you most proud of the
hardest was that chicken roof challenge
with the gigantic milkshake and I
remember going down to bite the sandwich
I was like [ __ ] standing in front of the
table like oh no that's the milkshake
it was a eating in the shadow of like
this giant dairy building
I remember finishing it and my sound guy
Eric he noticed he says like I started
taking individual slices of turkey off
the sandwich he said oh [ __ ] and I was
in trouble and I did this finished the
milkshake and I remember thinking as I
walked out I'm like could anyone pat me
on the back like like jostles me I'm
done I'm gonna look like a pinata and I
remember it was like a zen-like skill I
was like the debutante balancing the
book I'm like just just let me lay down
well that's how you know you left
everything out on the Hort you know what
I'm saying I did that I left the rest of
this and then stressed about to run mmm
so good
so I want to stay on the topic of man
vs. food because I think that there are
a lot of connections between man versus
food and hot ones caught one in the
throat yeah don't mug like you're
British urgent and um when the Christmas
carols so while eating wild pride cometh
before the fall realistically how long
do you think I have doing that before I
just spontaneously awesome you don't
apply
I've been watching you I think you're a
little bit like Bishop the guy in aliens
that like secretly has been an Android
the whole time if you find out you're
like not bad for a human that I watched
you your big fan of this yes the miyagi
sing because I'm a table pounder and I'm
I just saw like the whole Bennigan's
high-top thing that we have here and I'm
like oh
I needed to bring like an obelisk or a
plinth or just something to pound on
like just Wapner wouldn't you group your
separation okay go ahead
I haven't had aardvark for like any kind
of like roast meat sandwich if you do
like a steak sandwich a primary has just
enough heat to cut the richness all
right it is good hmm so I know that
you're a big fan of both brands of
football whether it's the NFL or the
English Premier League Oh Walmart up on
a fan level what's the difference
between going to a game and seeing you
know Tottenham Hotspur versus the Miami
Dolphins okay Jets dolphins is like
maybe Yankees BoSox whereas Tottenham
Arsenal is more like Palestine in Israel
it's deeply tribal you can have a Packer
fan sitting next to a bear fan at
Soldier Field they'll exchange words but
usually not much else at a British
football match there's a separate
entrance for away fans there's one
corner essentially dedicated to the away
fans that's lined by two lines of police
officers I know friends in England that
are like no more died
supports Norwich I support Norwich my
son will support Norwich and it's it
like and that's that's the way they
think that's the way it's hot so
supporting that to like you pledged your
allegiance to and then you can like kind
of like the others but it ain't the same
thing exactly I did a show with hot ones
alarm Charlie sloth and he was saying
Americans have to learn you got to type
the word and out of descendants so do
you support
you can actually make a face like
auricular so you have the distinction of
having wrapped on sway and you shared a
stage with Warren G I know that you're
very much a hip-hop ad yes what's your
New York MC Mount Rushmore what's your
top four uh-huh nas biggie
can I count five and q-tip is one can
the air I've called Club and tribes in
my chahid and and gyro be just jam them
all together into one that would put
tribe and then I'm gonna say Method Man
if you could take any artist to co-host
a food show with you who would it be
Oh Donald lover man childish gambino
that guy just blows my mind he's just
the ultimate polymath put him on stage
and comedy sting killing it I remember
hearing camp during bonfire off of his
first album and I was like that's Donald
[ __ ] Glover like oh my god I'm bout
it I'm Tim Gambino a childish that is
not like a growing up daddy Styles no
[Music]
hmm I'll give the bomb stir fry sauce
and no PRP opini mushrooms some of that
some green onion maybe some like
slivered peanuts fire all right Adams we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that Gramm and what we do
is we do a deep dive on our guests
Instagram we pull interesting pictures
that need more context so I'll just show
you the picture that gives a ridge about
that your story yes sir sound good
mm-hmm the people who don't know the
tent and slam you drink a hot beverage
through it and as it begins to cave in
you eat it it liquefies the inside into
like a custard or a ganache it's so dank
but I've convinced it is the most
fattening cookie like [ __ ] love handles
like full of Bannister
worth it absolutely oh my god were the
best taste of Australia and down
mountain chicken salt blow you and Diplo
loves to be a bromance between you and
Diplo so we were filming man finds food
Vegas
I went to club access and I met I knew
the security guards guy Andre I
mentioned I said as Wes here there's
karma is real Mike I'm sorry it will
hear he's like I knew where he went
I'm not going to say that picture was
taken from respect whistles our
integrity ah but that was a long night
that was one of those nights with my
whole film crew we were at establishment
we opened it was like Las Vegas so I was
like sinner you've been napping all
night really like it was like that the
end was like the vampire accidentally
walks out into the Sun that was that
night so this is dirty dicks
aggressive brand name we had really okay
I'll tell you this I'm trying to be like
thorough with it one of the most clever
bites boss here now we're going to wake
up a little bit TV or else a post Malone
had some very good attacks I notice that
he was kind of like pop it pop him very
wisely I'm not I'm not as wise I'm not
as why so close I just want to say
congratulations so you're really a man's
man a bros bro and that shines through
in your cookbook you know with recipes
for Fito sloppy joes or easy ass salsa
can you give me the adam richman
ultimate hangover cure sandwich in as
much detail as possible this is
something that actually exists I got
coffee
the ultimate hangover egg Sammy sock egg
whites are doing whole eggs in a pan I
do an omelet and I mix in Samuel Adams
cream stout or a good cream stout into
the eggs parsley garlic salt I do
sun-dried tomatoes and I get the ones
that are packed in oil for this sandwich
the liberty I use some of the oil
actually into the egg to flavor it and
then I get mozzarella and I'll do it on
I like a toasted casual mozzarella
sun-dried tomatoes cream stout and on a
roll
like Max Payne when you take that drug
like like super Scion you know you're
back I'm ready yeah exactly
zombie apocalypse okay so this one's
been a staple here for a while yeah sure
that wasn't Nicole that wondered because
their heads were exposed if zombies
would eat their own brain mm-hmm very
Nick Kroll TriNet thought right there I
actually used to audition opposite Nick
Kroll back Norman come up I came out of
Yale Drama and oh three and there's a
catch as well I feel that [ __ ] now
better shut up just get this one down
well this bumper zombie Ibaka
okay slugs are going so if you ask me
Travel Channel's heyday with no
reservations and man versus food and
Bizarre Foods yeah really just assured
in this whole new era of celebrity chef
and TV food personality and then you
even posted that one picture he called
you Anthony Bourdain and Andrew Zimmern
the Gang Gang of great Travel Channel
really kind of had over something very
special because you truly were able to
hit especially the food realm from so
many different standpoints because you
have someone like Anthony so deeply
acerbic deeply polarizing zero filter
confrontational to the point of
caricature at a point abrasive to the
point of caricature to a point then you
had Andrew he doesn't have the sharp
edges that Tony does and Andrew brought
in a sort of shock factor to it but the
reason it kept from being jackass is
because Andrew would imbue it with a
degree of heart and a degree of culinary
anthropology and a degree of some
learnin nature which is kind of endemic
to Andrew as a man and then
generationally there was an opportunity
for me culinarily there was an
opportunity to me no one was doing just
really kick-ass chili parlors no one was
doing food challenge programming at all
so I feel that there was that was the
chemistry it was that Tony had the
wizened Jonathan Swift with a cat you
know with like a cookbook Andrew was a
little bit more warm and friendly family
vacations to the unknown willy wonka ish
and i just wanted to be your friend
[Music]
love the technique love the technique
it's all coming back oh good older fast
all wrong
yeah mm-hmm
I just what the bike see overall Wow Wow
so Mario Batali he might be known for
his Crocs but I think that it was a TV
food personality game you're maybe the
most celebrated sneaker head when he
think about the time he spent an absurd
amount of money on shoes do any standout
rock star LeBron nines yeah I leave from
undefeated came into my boys shop he
explained that there were three
generations of them that the gold check
was like the most elite hyper-strike
that would give me 40 pairs made that
you know you always have to be careful
the births and the cost of this game
that's that's the one because the verb
when it comes up
that's what leapt down at your noble
honorable mention to the king push push
a tyonne's the black ones fish-scale but
those a dope that was the first kick
that my mom actually gave me props on my
mom was like that was some lovely you
know I like what is this like alligator
like reptile on the heel bubbly um I
gather they actually came in a bag that
smelled like cocaine is named for again
in Pusha T I don't
I know that you're going to use the
final dab with this one so I'm just a
muscle to it
[Music]
we're doing some piece into the nostrils
yeah hmm are you remembering what it's
like just like the end of two thousand
to one it's like I'm like it all bad in
a room somewhere doctor like calm
o'clock there's like a [ __ ] walking
backwards
yep times my arms Bend back complete
reference on a date a lot in high school
you know what it's so some of your more
casual fans might be surprised to learn
that you graduated from the Yale School
of Drama to write what's called the Yale
School of Drama and then you had small
roles and Law & Order and all my
children before man versus food was ever
a saying true was the show business
dream always about 72-ounce stakes and
gargantuan meals or could it have shaped
a little bit differently
I had already been acting and I love
performing but I also look that's the
one I by the way put some sauce right
here just now oh dude how does that
drama background help you when you're in
a career where you're sort of restaurant
hobbies the kitchen the kitchen need
those meals so it was my passion for
food my passion for performing and that
was the thing like I realized at Yale
that there was a significant difference
between being a good performer and a
good actor and hosting was actually
really quite perfect in terms of acting
training sure man you have to like keep
track of the shape of the show shows in
a four act structure you have to push
narrative when I've got long voiceover
that's all breath support raising the
stakes of the challenges at the end of
the day it's a four pound plate of
nachos the dough right needs to drop
exactly so you have to amp it up but you
also have to keep it within the realm of
semi reality if why is my right I didn't
put any finger or even chicken wing in
my right nostril if I squirted this in
my nose it
burn more than that right nostril like
it's bad it's like I'm like a Hilton
sisters circa like 2006 I kind of pulled
rip what truth like just all Scott
Disick in here
all right Adam Richman at that time the
dev I won't do it I won't do it we won't
do it so this is hot one the last dab
this is made with pepper X have you
tried pepper X I have tried this sauce
on wings on one on wings and just
straight mainlining it anyway so it's
not the easiest to dab wet which might
be an issue going forward before you go
alright I'm flattening less this that's
the thing when you have the flat 2 flat
necessitates pull on lip axis Moser yeah
yeah yeah yeah totally like you're gonna
have to go and take like a Silkwood
shower and I wear to rock again there's
nowhere to rot no no no exactly not not
enough where that's that good but
because I feel look like a little bit of
a [ __ ] one compared to you if you want
to go off you want to go there Adam
Julie go there so you should match
that's a not warning for y'all sea level
10 of 10 caution all it takes is a dab
to turn hot ones guess and fans alike
and to stuttering fire everything
lunatics
that's good copy Sean burger did you
write that is among the world's hottest
but there's pleasure in the pain thanks
to a healthy head of mustard ginger and
do you say tumeric turmeric or turmeric
turmeric that's what I say too
and it says it's a tough one and then
that second egg folks it's a tough one
alright Adam going down all right shall
we buy Oh see you guys toast social and
tradition too
thank as much chicken into canceled up
got mustard it's all cons on them I got
reversal though about the first opening
salvo hmm so that's what swallowing is
somebody that would be like got it mmm
what you know who it's literally like
you put a needle through my tongue like
like the worst Lollapalooza piercing
ever it's like you pierce my tongue and
my throat that's great dude Tuco Chris
D'Elia my [ __ ] is way alright Adam
Richman have one more question for you I
know you're a guy who's been to the top
of the mountain you've stared down the
biggest burgers you've eaten the hottest
Chili's but now it's time to let the
people know what they really want to
know where does hot ones rank on the
pantheon of great food challenges are we
a formidable opponent
are we just another half-ass bar
challenge that your producers would just
wouldn't even do in a heartbeat no I
think this is actually really clever I
think number one when so much of your
mind is dedicated to surviving that
you're going to get a kind of honesty
out of people I mean itís kind of the
brilliant concedes when I watch the show
wow I'm like the dog and Turner and
hooch right now wow I am really drool
fact to his deep but no I think that's
really input also that you really chosen
sauces that have the bomb is me the most
devoid of flavor I you know it is just
meant to hurt you but you've chosen
really good sauces with flavors to me
like the biggest problem it's already
starting now is the small like supernova
the small like celestial body if I like
went to a barbecue and just like
hopping coals back in like M&Ms but this
is a good challenge like because its
flavor and there's heat and it goes up
like there's there's a story it's not
just like let's put battery acid and a
burger and see if it hurts somebody oh
yes so how do you recommend people use
that like how do they use it on food
like do you like drop it like you put
like a drop in your kitchen once like
just anywhere in your kitchen it will
flavor everything for a year Adam
Richman you made it through you cleared
the board I had a feeling you would this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life oh it's awesome I feel like
remember deal on soul this is plug 1 all
right
so follow me on social media add Adam
Richman snapchat is og Adam Richman my
first book is called America the edible
a hundred history from seated dining see
my second book is called traded tasty
and it's a really cool cookbook meals
memories and mouseholes from I travel
these douchey cookbook you ever find
Plus as the entire history of chocolate
as a rhyming poem and we teach you to
cook in haiku and the charity life
support our clear path for veterans
check them out and I'm hosting a bunch
of pop-ups for common threads a charity
devoted to helping underprivileged kids
with healthier lives
[Music]
I was awesome I was I made you as weird
as I'm burning in the most unusual
places here yeah this nostril and the
half of my tongue it's crazy
[Music]
hello world Sean Evans coming at you to
say thank you for watching if you liked
what you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the 3000th rank
YouTube channel in the world it has been
a childhood dream of mine to be
somewhere in the mid twos we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please
jk jk no pressure but if you do
subscribe I appreciate it